- Bien oui! Bien oui! Bien o
l'argent ne pousse pas dans
les arbres, répétait François
Legault, encore aujourd'hui.
Une attaque dirigée contre
et solidaires.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT, chef CAQ
- Ce qu'on voit, dans les deuxé
déposés, c'est inquiétant,
parce que c'est pas
le temps de jouer au cowboyQuéb.
- Le chef de la CAQ affirme
que son cadre financier, lui,
est responsable. Sur un horizons
entraîneraient des nouvelles
dépenses de 29 milliards $.
La majeure partie serviraitcer ,
comme des baisses d'impôts,
pour que les Québécois puissent
faire face à l'augmentatiodu co.
- Actuellement, la principale
préoccupation des Québécois,
je pense que tous les députél'o,
c'est l'inflation.
- La saine gestion des finances
publiques est une
- Dans son rapport préélectoral,
le mois dernier, Éric Girard
prévoyait un retour à
l'équili
cinq ans. Cet objectif est
d'ailleurs maintenrs maintenu ds
le cadre financier de la CAQ.
Or, les
plus importants que prévu.
chain, il frôlerait
les 8 milliards de dollars.
mais elle n'aurait pas beaucoup
de nouvelles sources de revenus,
hormis la croissance anticipée
ÉRIC GIRARD
ministre des Finances, Québec
- Avec le stimuli fiscal que
c'est certain que ça va soutenir
l'économie. Ça va aider.
- Dans un contexte économique
le mot récession sur les lèvres,
c'est au tour de François
Legault de goûter à la médecine
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, chef PLQ
- La CAQ s'invente des revenus
qui sont basés sur absolument
rien, sinon que du vent.
Parti conservateur du Québec
- Malheureusement, il nous
a annoncé qu'il allait piger ça
dans le Fonds des générationherr
l'argent qui est destiné
aux jeunes et il va transférer
ça pour baisser les impôts.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUB-parole QS
- Moi, j'en reviens pas
qu'il n'y ait même pas
le mot changement climatique
dans son cadre financier.
que les cadres financiers
du Parti québécoisti
conservateur, que tous les deux
promettent de dévoiler
avant le